merci alors on est en 2008
c'est ma première année d'études j'ai
des rêves plein la tête et je commence à
utiliser un service qui s'appelle
facebook
ce service me plaît tellement en fait
que j'ai envie d'investir dans cette
entreprise
sauf qu'à ce moment là pour pouvoir y
investir pour avoir un peu d'argent
notamment comme un certain li ka shing
qui a un milliardaire hong kongais et
qu'ils avaient investie en mars 2008 60
millions de dollars dans facebook
j'aurais bien voulu m'aligner mais je
les avais pas en tout cas ça me donne
envie d'investir dans des start up et je
regarde autour de moi rien y'a pas un
site rien en 2011
c'est ma dernière année d'études j'ai
toujours des rêves plein la tête et
facebook c'est plutôt bien développé à
tel point que c'est une entreprise qui
va s'introduire en bourse
et je crois toujours énormément son
potentiel j'ai toujours envie d'investir
dedans
et là encore pour pouvoir y investir il
faut un peu d'argent c'est un petit peu
baissé mais il faut plus d'un million de
dollars et il vaut mieux être client
privé chez goldman sachs pour pouvoir y
avoir accès j'aurais bien voulu ma
lignée mais je les avais pas je vais
vous dire un truc je les ai toujours pas
cette histoire n est pas anodine
parce qu'elle fait partie de ce qui
motive à ce moment là à vouloir
développer un mécanisme qui permettrait
de se rassembler à plusieurs et d'avoir
accès à ce genre de projet ça me
semblait incroyable qu'on puisse pas
accéder à des entreprises à fort
potentiel avant la bourse
en fait à ce moment il y avait des
mécanismes qui existaient pour les
chanteurs on pouvait se réunir et être
micro producteurs il y avait aussi un
mot qui revenait de plus en plus qui
commence à frémir aux états unis et ce
mot là c'est le crowdfunding c'est un
mot un peu barbare qu'est ce que c'est
que le crowdfunding c'est justement ce
mécanisme qui permet de se rassembler à
plusieurs et de financer un projet donné
en fait c'est tout simplement quand la
somme des parties va permettre de
réaliser ce qu'un seul individu n'aurait
jamais pu faire seul
donc convaincu et je vais investir
toutes mes économies ça veut dire un
prêt étudiant et me lancer dans un
ménage à trois avec mes associés
caroline et joachim passant dans une
start-up garage mais dans un startup
studio de 18 mètres carrés on a beaucoup
à faire
même pas peur on se lance on est sûr que
les français en voudront bon en fait on
va se frotter à quelques petites
complications
il ya notamment des complications
réglementaire à l'époque les plateformes
était à minima dans une zone grise ou au
pire hors la loi on s'arme de courage et
ont créé une association professionnelle
qui va réunir tous les acteurs du
secteur pour parler d'une seule voix et
à cette époque on est portée par un
formidable élan dans la presse qui se
passionnent pour ce mode de financement
donc on va rencontrer les organismes
patronaux
on va rencontrer les halls les autorités
de tutelle on va rencontrer les
associations du monde du financement de
l'investissement les politiques et
toutes ces personnes là nous regarde un
petit peu et bay devant une bande de
beatniks et ils soient assez peu habitué
en fait à avoir des sollicitations de
personnes comme nous pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont plutôt habitués à rencontrer
des personnes aux cheveux blancs ou
grisonnants et en costume avec une
cravate et rasé de près c'est pas grave
on s'arme de courage et par force de
conviction et quelques coups de pouce
notamment celui de fleur pellerin en
après ces deux ans de combat on va
arriver à l'émergence de deux statues
qui nous permette d'exercer dont un kit
à une brèche dans le monopole bancaire
vous avez bien entendu il t'a une brèche
dans le monopole bancaire
il ya une chose incroyable c'est que le
crowdfunding va permettre à des français
de prêter directement à des entreprises
sans risquer de se retrouver en prison
pour exercice illégal de la profession
de banquier
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire c'est pas tellement cette
première marche qui a été franchi mais
c'est surtout d'essayer de comprendre
comment ils ont pu faire confiance à
cette bande de beatniks un peu rêveur
pourquoi ils nous ont donné cette chance
la première raison elle est toute simple
c'est que c'est un mouvement qui venait
du peuple pour le peuple en fait les
français voulaient tout simplement
participer à leur économie et c'est un
mode de financement qui n'existaient pas
donc il fallait que ces plates formes
existent les pouvoirs publics devaient
rendre cela possible
la deuxième chose c'est que la confiance
elle est inhérente au système fait une
campagne de corning
c'est des dizaines des centaines parfois
des milliers de particuliers qui vont
passer un projet open feint qui vont
voter avec leur argent et qu'ils vont
dire oui moi je vais prêter ou investir
dans un tel projet plutôt que tel autre
et ça s'autorégule entre les bons et les
moins bons projets c'était très
chaotique
on n'avait pas beaucoup de chances au
départ mais on a fait pas mal de choses
en cinq ans et maintenant on peut
légitimement se poser la question de la
suite
qu'est ce qui va se passer qu'est ce qui
nous reste à prouver qu est ce qui nous
reste à faire pour moi il ya deux
éléments essentiels qui nous reste à
prouver dans ce mode de financement
la première chose c'est le pari de
l'intelligence collective et si le
crowdfunding permettait de sélectionner
sur le long terme de meilleur projet
pour ça une petite expérience que je
vous invite à faire chez vous pas
dangereuse vous prenez un bocal vous y
mettez des fraises tagada ça va marcher
aussi avec les réglisses et les
schtroumpfs et vous allez voir un grand
nombre de personnes et vous leur posez
cette question combien de fraises tagada
se trouve dans ce bocal
les réponses en fait elles seront
réparties sur une courbe de gauss et au
centre on trouvera à une ou deux près le
nombre exact de fraises tagada c'est un
peu simpliste mais c'est là pour
illustrer le fait qu'avec une bonne
information mis à disposition du
collectif on peut en tirer une
intelligence la deuxième chose qui nous
reste à prouver
la deuxième chose qui nous reste à
prouver
c'est une adoption massive de ce mode de
financement par les français c'est un
projet ambitieux mais les français
veulent participer à leur économie
veulent participer à la construction de
leur paysage ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'ils sont déjà prêtes 3 millions à
avoir participé à ce mode de financement
et dans ses 3 millions
il ya des personnes qui ont contribué au
financement de calais litho ce qui est
un programme immobilier qui a vu le jour
grâce à la participation d'une centaine
d'investisseurs qui a reçu une pyramide
d'argent pour son architecture
c'est pour ça que je me lève tous les
matins ils ont aussi participé à des
projets comme wonder kraft qui est une
équipe de jeunes polytechniciens qui
développe un exosquelette qui va
permettre aux paraplégiques de retrouver
le sens de la marche qui a d'abord lever
l'argent au crowdfunding puis auprès
d'institutionnels 4 millions d'euros
puis 15 millions d'euros pour réaliser
cette vision c'est pour ça que je me
lève tous les matins
en fait si je me lève tous les matins
c'est pour vivre le futur au présent et
tout ça je les réalise et pour cet
étudiant en 2008 qui voulaient investir
dans facebook jeunes a aussi réalisé
pour ces entreprises qui ont l'envié de
devenir les facebook de demain mais en
fait j'ai surtout fait pour vous je les
fais pour que vous puissiez vous aussi
vive le futur au présent merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]